everybody knows the spider-man everybody
knows Superman everybody doesn't know
Harriet Tubman Demon Slayer I wanted our
focus to be diverse titles we are
actively working to make sure we have
books that you just may not see in other
shops my name is Arielle Johnson and I'm
the owner and operator aka head nerd in
charge of amalgam comics and coffee
house a comic book store devoted to
diversity when I was about 11 or so I
was introduced to the x-men I really
connected with storm because she looked
like me white hair and white eyes of
five it was out of my love of her
character that I got into comic books
once I graduated I did struggle with
finding my place in the world I wasn't
quite happy in my career and after a
conversation between my sister my
brother-in-law they gave me that extra
push that I needed to do the thing that
I get excited about fast forward and
we're here and we've been here three
years in building amalgam I wanted my
comic book store to focus on diversity
because I know what it's like to not be
represented we also take stuff to make
sure people know that they're welcome
here from the books that we start on the
shelves from the people that I have
working here everything about the space
is diverse I know creators have had
stories about dealing with stores and
publishers getting their work published
or in a store and sometimes it is just
very much like well this is too
different from what we normally sell so
we don't want to take a chance on it but
Malcolm Blair
Seana lien is an indie creator who has
been a longtime supporter of am album we
have carried his books in the past and
currently we're carrying his line of
t-shirts
well the name of my comic book is the
almighty street team is a collaborative
urban superhero martial-arts comic book
usually the comic bust I create stay
close to the stuff I grew up loving
which was like the urban street
characters I did have some trouble a
place in the book and stores but we
found a home and I'm album right away
she got the ideas she got the vision and
she connected with the book but I see
the support to the indie comic book
creators it makes you feel like hey yeah
I can continue to make a living doing
this when I open the shop so many people
said this is what we've always needed
I've always wanted a place like this we
have had an overwhelmingly positive
response from our local community the
geek community beyond the blur candy who
your geek community people are excited
that this space exists and if you have
something that you want to see in your
community my challenge would be to do
the work to see if it's something that
you can do I don't think that people
should keep waiting to be saved by
someone else you can be your own
superhero
[Music]